eight months ago I was diagnosed with
gender dysphoria while I was inpatient
here in UW-Madison I looked into the
research and like talked to doctors and
through my journey I decided to explore
medically transitioning you know because
it's shown to decrease suicidal ideation
stuff like that and since then although
I've had to deal with other issues such
as transphobia and sexual assault I've
been more happier overall than I ever
was before my question to you is what
specifically about medically
transitioning do you think is so immoral
that we should ignore the potential
benefits and why should I listen to you
as somebody who's not a medical
professional and has not experienced
gender dysphoria there's a dishonesty
behind it dishonesty in the false
promises that they make which is that
you can attain this image of maleness or
femaleness that you can actually become
in some ways the the opposite gender or
sex whatever words you want to use which
is a lie it's not true